Imagina un país con menos población que
el barrio de Manhattan pero que tiene reservas
de petróleo y de gas natural.
Un país que está rodeado de las petromonarquías más ricas del mundo ¿De qué país estamos
hablando?
¡Exacto!
De BAHREIN; un país tan pequeño que a duras
penas lo vemos en el mapa.
A estas alturas, seguro que todos pensáis
que la vida es maravillosa en este lugar.
Dinero para todos, economía próspera y crecimiento
sin igual ¿Verdad?
Pues… lo cierto es que las cosas no van
precisamente bien por aquí…
“Bahréin es degradada a la categoría basura,
mientras la represión política continúa
sin cesar”
Habéis oído bien.
La deuda de Bahréin está considerada como
bono basura en el mercado internacional.
Es decir, que hay dudas muy serias de que
su economía sea lo suficientemente sólida
como para devolver sus préstamos.
¡Y lo cierto es que las cosas en Bahreim
son de todo menos tranquilas!
Si seguís VisualPolitik desde hace tiempo,
ya sabéis que dentro del mundo islámico
hay dos grandes grupos: los sunnitas y los
chiitas.
Y se llevan a matar.
Literalmente.
Si queréis entender mejor las diferencias
entre unos y otros, en la descripción os
dejo un vídeo donde lo explicamos a fondo.
Lo cierto es que Arabia Saudita es el país
sunnita por antonomasia.
Y la República de Irán es la Disneylandia
del Islam Chiita.
Y por eso llevan inmersos en una guerra fría
durante décadas.
Pues bien, en Baréin tienen una situación
cuanto menos curiosa: la mayoría de la población
es chiíta pero la Casa Real que los gobierna
es sunnita.
Y eso explica que los reyes de Baréin hayan
hecho de la opresión, un auténtico arte.
Pero vale, hasta aquí todo normal.
Lo que ahora os estaréis preguntando es…
¿Por qué decimos que Baréin puede convertirse
en el país más rico del mundo?
Pues… por esto.
“Bahréin descubre el yacimiento petrolífero
más grande del país desde 1932’”
Hablamos de zumo de dinosaurio a cascoporro.
Chorros y chorros de petróleo.
De repente, Baréin podría tener más petróleo
que Rusia pero con una centésima parte de
la población.
Vamos, que hay pocos para repartir el dinero.
Así que ahora la pregunta es… ¿Es esto
suficiente para que Baréin se convierta en
el país más rico del mundo?
¿Por qué, teniendo tanto petróleo, se sigue
considerando que su deuda es bono basura?
¿Qué está pasando en este país?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
UNA JAULA DE ORO
Veréis, si algún día queréis convertiros
en dictador de un país, tenéis dos modos
para hacerlo: la más obvia es la clásica
mano dura de toda la vida ¿Problema?
Que si reprimes demasiado, te arriesgas a
un levantamiento popular.
Os lo hemos dicho mil veces en VisualPolitik,
ser dictador es una profesión de riesgo.
Pero hay otra alternativa mucho más sostenible,
la de las “manos llenas”.
Es decir, cubre de dinero a tus ciudadanos.
Si no tienen que preocuparse por buscar trabajo,
tampoco tendrán que preocuparse por la política.
Suena bien ¿verdad?
Pues la familia AL KHALIFA, que es la dinastía
que reina en Baréin, mezcla las dos cosas.
Para que os hagáis una idea, el Primer Ministro,
que es el tío del rey, tiene el record mundial
de longevidad en el cargo.
Lleva en el poder desde 1971.
Sin embargo ¿Cómo consigue una dinastía
de confesión sunnita aguantar tanto tiempo
en el poder cuando la población chiíta?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
Como decíamos antes, tenemos la clásica
y tradicional mano dura de toda la vida ¿Protestas
contra el gobierno?
A la cárcel, pena de muerte o, simplemente,
te echamos del país ¡Y no os creamos que
hablamos de un caso aislado!
Es algo que ocurre todas las semanas.
“Bahréin retira la nacionalidad a 115 personas
por acusaciones de “terrorismo”
Más de 700 personas en Bahréin han visto
revocada su ciudadanía desde 2012”
Y sí, ya sé lo que me vais a decir “Fonseca,
que en otros países democráticos también
retiran la ciudadanía” Por supuesto.
Pero, como siempre, la diferencia está en
las medidas.
En Reino Unido, los casos se cuentan por decenas.
En Baréin estamos hablando de cientos.
Y si pensabais que las cosas están evolucionando…
estáis muy, pero que muy equivocados.
En 2011, durante las primaveras árabes, el
pueblo chiita salió a las calles a pedir
más democracia.
La respuesta no se hizo esperar: Arabia Saudí
empezó a mandar tropas a Bahréin por la
calzada del Rey Fahd, uno de los puentes más
grandes del mundo.
Con la ayuda de Emiratos Árabes, se reprimieron
violentamente las protestas.
A día de hoy, 1 de cada 500 personas en Baréin
es un preso político.
Y entre ellos están los líderes de los grupos
chiítas, que llevan varios años entre rejas.
¡No sólo eso!
Desde 2011, Baréin ha aprobado leyes para
facilitar los trámites de pérdida de ciudadanía.
Y perder la ciudadanía bareiní es mucho
peor de lo que parece a simple vista.
Retirar la ciudadanía supone convertirles
en personas apátridas, sin derechos.
Los condenados entregan su documento de identidad,
su licencia de conducir, no pueden tener una
casa, un coche, un teléfono, una cuenta bancaria.
No pueden casarse ni registrar legalmente
un hijo.
Los que se exilian, no podrán volver.
Y los que optan por quedarse, no podrán salir
del país.
En definitiva, los que se oponen al Gobierno
se convierten en ciudadanos de segunda.
Y, creedme, es una auténtica desgracia.
Porque, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
ser un ciudadano de primera, es toda una bendición.
Y aquí es cuando entra la política de las
“manos llenas”.
Lo que podríamos llamar el contrato social
bareiní.
Básicamente, si te olvidas de la política,
vives del cuento: ¿Buscas trabajo?
¡Tienes un hueco en la administración pública!
Y tranquilo, nadie te va a pedir que sudes
demasiado… ¿Tienes que ir al supermercado?
¡Los alimentos están subvencionados!
¿Echar gasolina al coche?
¡Precios por los suelos!
¿Y qué pasa si quieres trabajar en la empresa
privada?
¡No te preocupes!
El Gobierno garantiza cuotas de trabajadores
que tienen que ser locales.
Ningún inmigrante te quitará el puesto de
trabajo.
Y, esta es la mejor parte, esas cuotas están
pensadas para que los bareiníes de primera
puedan trabajar en los puestos más agradables.
Por ejemplo, en los bancos de Bahréin el
50% de los trabajadores tienen que ser locales.
En las tiendas de ropa, un 30%.
Pero en la construcción solo se exige un
5% ¿Por qué?
Porque para poner ladrillos, es mejor contratar
a inmigrantes.
Para que os hagáis una idea, el 55% de la
población de este país son extranjeros.
Y son los que realmente trabajan en el país.
Y aquí tengo que hacer un PARÉNTESIS.
Porque veréis, eso de tener más población
inmigrante que local es algo muy típico de
la zona.
Para que os hagáis una idea, Qatar tiene
casi un 75% de extranjeros.
Sin embargo, Baréin es uno de los pocos países
de la zona que han abolido la llamada KAFALA.
¿Y qué es la KAFALA, os preguntaréis?
Pues es algo así como esclavitud moderna.
El sistema kafala hace que los trabajadores
extranjeros estén ligados a un ciudadano
nacional que es su patrocinador y que es el
que decide sobre cuestiones como permitir
si puede cambiar de trabajo e incluso si puede
abandonar el país o no.
Pues bien, Baréin lo tiene abolido, así
que, un aplauso para ellos.
Sin embargo y pese a todo, lo que ahora os
estaréis preguntando todos es… ¿Este sistema
donde casi nadie trabaja es económicamente
sostenible?
Pues la respuesta es rotunda: NO.
120 DÓLARES
Vivir sin trabajar es muy caro.
Y si en Baréin se lo pueden permitir es simple
y llanamente por una cosa: petróleo.
El zumo de dinosaurio supone más de un 60%
de las exportaciones del país y un 75% de
los ingresos del Estado.
El problema es que para cubrir todos los gastos,
el Gobierno necesita que el barril de crudo
cotice a 120 dólares.
Si vale menos, no tienen suficiente beneficio.
Y diréis ¿120 dólares es mucho o poco?
En su máximo histórico, en julio de 2008,
el petróleo cotizó a 147 dólares.
Pero como bien sabéis, en el año 2014, los
precios del petróleo empezaron a caer.
En enero de 2016 llegaron a 26 dólares.
Y eso explica cosas como esta.
“Standard and Poor’s reduce el rating
de Bahréin a ‘B+’”
Así que ante el bajo precio del crudo y la
falta de ingresos, el Estado ha recurrido
al endeudamiento.
El resultado habla por sí solo.
La deuda pública está ha pasado del 7 al
70% en sólo dos años.
Y aunque los precios del crudo están volviendo
a subir… no parece probable que volvamos
a ver los 120 dólares en mucho tiempo.
En Bahrein ya han tenido que quitar las subvenciones
a la carne, y eso es sólo el princpio.
“Bahréin lanzará el IVA a finales de 2018,
según el ministro de finanzas”
Habéis oído bien.
En Baréin no hay impuestos de la renta…
y hasta no tenían impuesto sobre el valor
añadido.
Pero la situación es desesperada y no les
queda otra que empezar no a subir sino, simplemente,
a crear impuestos que antes no existían.
Pero y todo esto… ¿Qué puede suponer en
Bahréin?
Pensadlo bien, todo el sistema se basa en
lo siguiente: el pueblo chiíta acepta unos
déspotas sunnitas a cambio de vivir sin dar
un palo al agua.
Así que si la economía falla, la política
también.
Sólo un milagro podría salvar a la dinastía
de los AL KHALIFA y ese milagro es este.
TÍTULO: PETRÓLEO A MANOS LLENAS
Bahréin produce 200.000 barriles de crudo
diarios.
Realmente son pocos a nivel global pero es
una barbaridad para el tamaño del país.
Como ya os he dicho, Bahréin ha descubierto
este año un enorme yacimiento de petróleo.
Y podrían estar empezando a bombear zumo
de dinosaurio en 5 años.
Según los más optimista, esto duplicaría
la producción y acabaría con el déficit.
¿El problema?
Que no todo el petróleo cuesta lo mismo.
El petróleo saudí de extraer.
¿Por qué?
Porque pinchas en la arena y ¡Pum!
Chorros de zumo de dinosaurio.
En Escocia, por ejemplo es más caro ¿Por
qué?
Porque está debajo del agua y necesitas plataformas
petrolíferas.
Sin embargo, este nuevo yacimiento tiene todas
los ingredientes para ser carísimo.
Primero, está bajo el agua y además es lo
que se llama “petróleo de esquisto”.
Es decir, que está incrustado en una roca
que hay que romper primero.
En otras palabras, que necesitan fracking
¿Y sabéis qué?
El fracking es de todo menos barato.
En esta gráfica podéis ver el coste de producción
de un barril de petróleo en distintos países.
No podemos hacernos una idea de lo que costaría
el fracking en Bahrein, pero podemos ver lo
que cuesta en Estados Unidos.
Si os fijáis, veréis que el barril de Esquisto
es sustancialmente más caro de producir que
el barril normal.
Para que Baréin pueda hacer un mínimo beneficio,
el petróleo tiene que estar por encima de
los 60 dólares.
Pero como en baréin necesitan unos beneficios
aún mayores para pagar sus gastos, ni siquiera
teniendo este yacimiento se van a salvar.
Entonces ¿Qué puede salvar a Baréin de
la ruina?
Pues… muy fácil, lo mismo que en todos
los países de la zona: diversificación.
Es decir, tener otras cosas que no sean petróleo.
Cosas como esta.
“Mondelez abre su `fábrica del futuro’
en Bahréin, invirtiendo 90 millones de dólares”
Pero claro, si realmente quieres atraer a
empresas de todos los sectores necesitas algo
más que yacimientos de petróleo.
Necesitas un sistema político serio, donde
los impuestos son claros, las reglas son claras
y el gobierno no puede meter en la cárcel
a quien le de la gana.
Lo hemos visto en muchísimos otros vídeos.
Dubai, y en general Emiratos Arabes Unidos
ya empezaron hace décadas a modernizar sus
sistemas.
Arabia Saudita está siguiendo el mismo camino.
Y es cuestión de tiempo que Baréin siga
el mismo ejemplo.
Sin embargo, aquí es donde está la pregunta
¿Creéis que los ciudadanos aceptarán un
gobierno tan autoritario ahora que les va
a obligar a pagar impuestos y trabajar?
¿O tal vez las reformas económicas tendrán
que ir acompañadas de reformas políticas?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y, por supuesto, no olvidéis visitar nuestra
página de Patreon, donde tendréis acceso
a contenido exclusivo.
Por cierto, suscribíos al canal de YouTube
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones
y si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE.
Nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto!